hey everybody thanks so much for joining
us today for our workflows with posit
team session if this is your first time
joining us we do host these workflows
the last Wednesday of every month and so
if you ever want to go back and check
out the recordings I think we've had
about seven of them so far um but today
you will learn from Gordon Shotwell
senior software engineer at posit who is
joining us to show how to use posit
connect as an endtoend python platform
for hosting internal machine learning
models I'll be hanging around in the
background here so if you have any
questions feel free to put them into the
chat I'll also put a slido in there
where you can ask
anonymously but with that thanks again
for joining us and I'll turn it over to
Gordon uh my name is Gordon Shotwell I'm
a software engineer at posit and I
mostly work on shiny for python but
before I worked at posit I was Mo I
worked uh in industry building uh tools
for training deploying and monitoring
machine learning models and I learned a
couple of patterns with posit connect
that I think are particularly useful and
I wanted to go through some of those uh
today so let's just get started by
taking a look at this um modeling code
and this is a very um simple uh maybe
probably in these days this day and age
primitive uh text classification model
that um basically classifies text based
on the words that are in that sentence
to determine whether it's about
Electronics or not and here we have sort
of the modeling code break the model
into training and test set fit the model
and then print out some accuracy some
some model
statistics and the question here is say
I'm happy with this model and I want to
share it with other people um how should
I do that and in particular um how
should I share it with all the different
groups of people that might need to
interact with either this model or the
data that underlies this model somehow
so this is kind of um the way I would
sort of break it up in terms of this
sort of imaginary situation where I'm
building a model I want to share it with
other people and I can think of five
groups um that uh um that uh need to use
this model so the first group is me like
the modelers me and my the team of
people who actually like generated this
model second group is leadership um who
might want to get model statistics or
have a sense of how model is performing
on the latest set of data third one is
the data team um these might be people
who use um code
to score the text that they're
encountering in their own data sets and
then finally we have these other two
groups one is a group of annotators this
is a group of people who might be um
annotating data to provide me with more
training data and improve the quality of
my models and there's this other this
last group that's just kind of other
systems that might come up you know
other group other people using other
programming languages maybe somebody
who's working on the website might need
to call this model for some
reason and all these groups have
different needs and importantly
different interfaces so model modelers
and the data team they're probably both
using python it might have some people
using R but in this case in this sort of
example say they're all using python um
leadership they probably just want to
see a static site you know they don't
need something super interactive they
just need to see something that gives
them a little print out of St
ICS and uh finally we have these
annotators and they're probably not
technical so they're going to need a
more of a full featured web app and
these other systems are going to
interact with some programming language
that maybe we don't know now or won't
know about in the
future one of my most um sort of
important principles when thinking about
these types of systems is this rule
which is apis before
uis so when we look at this group of
people see that there are a few
different groups that are using
something you might call an API it's a
code first interaction with this product
we have these python users and this this
um and these other systems which might
use some type of code and the reason why
I think apis before uiz is such a good
rule is that code interfaces are way
easier to build than guies they just
have fewer parameters you don't need to
worry about centering something or
making the UI kind of intuitive you can
just build the code and have people
interact with the code because they're
easier to build they're easier to change
and iterate
upon this means that if you're kind of
working mostly on an API you're going to
be able to make more changes more
quickly to Center in on the right
interaction the right data model and the
right type of user flow um for your
particular product in my experience
doing this for a number of years is that
a good UI a good API will usually create
a good UI both in terms of like the
Simplicity of the code and also how
intuitive it is once you've kind of
centered on that right um API the right
interaction for your problem
the goey that serves that type of
interaction is pretty obvious most of
the time the opposite is not true um
I've seen a lot of times people build um
a guey first and in doing that they kind
of just sort of throw different things
into some type of programming data model
or some type of of interface and trying
to build uh intuitive code interface
using those same data structures can be
really awkward so if you ever tried to
analyze web data as a data scientist
this is kind of why you get this big
giant blob of dat of Json that's not
particularly well structured um for your
purpose right so if you ever have the
option of building the code interface
first before doing any type of guey work
um I re really recommend doing this
doesn't always happen but in this case
we do right we have these these three
groups of people are us interested in
code um they're also probably our
earliest stakeholders so we might want
to serf them
first okay so one way of Distributing
this model is um to use a python package
right I could put this model in a python
package and have that package be
installed from something like posit
package package manager or Nexus or some
other package hosting system um but this
creates a few problems um there's and I
would say there's may there's three main
problems the first is that uh packages
are necessarily really hard to
authenticate and authorize so usually
when you look at um internal
repositories like piie like repositories
they don't have particularly
sophisticated security controls on who
can download um those packages but the
bigger problem is that once those
packages are downloaded from those
repositories they're just in the wild
there's no real way for us to control
who has access to them we can't create
fine grain controls for example give
some people access to one python
function in the package and other people
access to another one and if um the
individual human who just downloaded
that uh package shares it
inappropriately or um leaves their
laptop open and untended anything that's
in there including the model or any type
of data that's on that in that package
is going to be exposed right um so if
we're working on a Model that maybe
includes some sensitive intellectual
property or might encode some sensitive
data or expose some sensitive data and
that's going to be a really big problem
right we want to have the ability to
authenticate the model when it's called
and the second big problem with packages
is that they always require user input
to update so if I were to distribute
this model in a uh python package just
by itself if I ever changed the model or
change you know updated it or change
some part of how that model is called um
I would need to ask all of my Downstream
users to update their installation and
they would need to do that probably in a
lot of places so they may need to update
it in all the different virtual
environments they have on their computer
if theyve deployed assets toit connect
they would need to update all those
becomes an enormous Hassle and the final
reason is that that would need python
right not probably most of our users are
kind of comfortable using python but
some of them maybe aren't maybe I have
some our users at my company maybe
there's a Scola group that wants to call
this model and create adding python to
their um build environment is maybe
going to cause some
problems um an alternative and what I'm
going to choose here is to use an API
basically host Host this model as an API
on on posit
connect and have um some wrapper
functions that call that AP and this is
going to give me a couple of major
advantages the first is that um I'm
going to solve I'm going to solve all
three of the problems that I just
expressed right I'm going to be able to
update that model in one place by
re-uploading it to posit connect um I'll
be able to authenticate access to the
API both the the top level domain um and
also I can authorize any of the
endpoints that people call um and
finally it's going to be language
independent every programming language
has the ability to wrap and call apis so
if I can put something up as an API then
I'm going to be able to give access to
everybody um so I'm going to go through
kind of the overall diagram here and
then I'm going to take it piece by piece
and show you the code that I developed
for these projects so this is kind of
the big picture of what I'm trying to do
and I have kind of three groups here um
so the leadership I have data scientists
who might use both an our python package
and then I have these annotators and I'm
also showing um the interface that these
people are going to be using so this
leadership group they're going to be
looking at um Cordo rendered Cordo
document um these data scientists are
going to be interacting um through a
python or our package with an API and
then the annotators are going to be
interacting with a shiny app the API in
turn is going to call a data store and
um I'll show you what that is but I
would recommend probably this should be
a database that sort of lives outside of
connect but everything else um can exist
on connect
and the reason why I really love connect
for this purpose is that it gives me a
kind of safe space that I'm able to
deploy all these different types of
assets for all these different customer
all these different users without
needing to have a lot of conversations
with either devops security or any kind
of regulatory um situation at my company
right since I have posit connect set up
there's this one time investment of
getting that through all the different
layers of approval that you need to
implement something like this you can
secure it in a way that is compliant
with all of your company's policies but
once you've done that you can just
deploy these things to this product it
makes it a really useful uh prototyping
um solution both for sort small things
like a posit like a shiny app or a
jupyter notebook but also for these
larger interc connected systems right I
can validate that this whole thing works
with just me the data scientist doing
the work I don't need to involve other
people getting the infrastructure or
approving that
infrastructure all right so this this is
a lot um so we're going to start um with
this
API and um show you kind of the uh the
end point for this
API
um which is this API
here and so you see this API is a is a
fast API and it has a few different um
end points so I have the ability to
append training data to this um to this
this uh data set um I can score the
model I can update the model can get the
last um updated date and I can um query
the data and what's nice about this is
that uh this is um interactive Swagger
documentation so it'll give me kind of
some information about what this is
expecting this case it has no parameters
and it just gives you a successful
response or gives you a a string
response and I can try it out so I can
just click execute and it's going to
give me both the um curl command that I
used to call this the uh the request URL
and then also the response for this
particular thing and for some of these
that gets a little bit more
complicated um so I chose fast API for
one main reason and the main reason that
so fast API has a a few great benefits
like one is that it's very fast uh but
in my case I don't particularly care
about this being a fast API it's a very
simple one so any of them are going to
be fast enough um but what fast API um
gives you is this which which is um a
clear example of what data type this is
expecting so in this case it's expecting
a list um and then a Json object with
that is with a key value pair of text
with text annotator annotation these two
need to be string and this one needs to
be a
Boolean and the way that is produced if
I go back to my go over to my API code
here is by um creating um these pantic
models that um tell the API what it
should expect so here I'm able toine I'm
defining this training data class which
is just very simple sort of key value
model with these two these uh three keys
and these three value types and then uh
when I um create write my my python
function I'm able to uh refer to that
I'm saying this data I'm using type
annotation to say this data is expecting
a list of training data elements
and that list of trading data elements
is then going to generate um this
expected value not only will it sort of
generate that from the documentation
perspective but it's going to validate
that for me um so if somebody
sends Mal form um sends a different type
of uh of payload to this API it's going
to give me a 422 error um so for example
um if I take this annotator one out here
and I try executing it um the the
response I get is a 422 and that what
that means is that um I'm API is
expecting a particular form of data and
you didn't Supply that data so it's
going to give you informative error for
that without me the programmer needing
to write any of that validation I don't
need to do anything I just need to
declare in the um fast API type type
annotation that that's what I'm
expecting and then I'm going to get that
result
back so um I'm not going to go through
this code in too much detail this is
going to be a pretty high level sort of
architectural planning thing but um the
basic uh but a couple of but one thing I
did want to point out here is that um
I'm storing all this data on an on disk
sqlite database and that's mostly just
to um keep everything on connect without
building up too many dependencies um but
that particular if you were doing this
in reality I would recommend pulling
that out to another um uh to another
data store so that's kind of so the to
go through some of these models a little
bit I have um a pen training data which
just takes a list of those training data
elements um and sends them to pens them
to my uh sqlite data store I have um a
model scoring endpoint which um opens up
the latest model that's been that's been
uploaded um and returns a single score
so it's taking a text a bit of text and
returning that score I have the ability
to um update this model so I have an
update model endpoint which takes uh
both the um machine learning model and
the vectorizer to sort of turn your text
into the right uh features um and um
finally I have a query data endpoint
which is just sending a query and
getting a result of that
query and a couple of test endpoints to
just let me understand you know is this
API working and things like
that the way um that you uh um so the
way that this model is intended to be
used for the most part is I want to
allow people to some people to upload
models I want allow people some people
to append data and I want other people
to be able to score the model or query
it and when I'm doing that I this is
kind of this notion of authorization
right so I want to be able to sort of
authenticate everybody who's joining um
who's uh seeing this API but I want I
want to authorize a couple of people to
do some endpoints and I'm able to do
that um with this uh
um this uh validate and validate access
uh function here so this this function
is basically asking is user user in this
control list um and if it's not Ray is a
401 and that
um uh user user is generated by this
function which is get current user um
which just looks for um the uh
information in the um header that's pass
deposit
connect and what that is going to allow
me to do is basically say get the the
person who's accessing or viewing this
API and respond with either you can
access it or you can't um as a as a
401 so the result of that is that um I
have a couple of endpoints which are
available to everybody like score model
so if you were to log open this up and
um try to score this score model you
would be able to do that so you could
try this out
say I am a computer I think it's
probably not going to give me a very
good score here um but here you see I'm
getting 200 with the score from that
model but if you were to try to um uh to
update a model um or to uh query the
data you're going to get a 401 error I
won't get a 401 error because I'm sort
one of the people who are uh who's who's
allowed to view
it
okay so that's the that's um um mostly
the API and uh this has a couple of
benefits so the main couple benefits
we've just talked about are it allows me
to authorize these features and allows
me to keep my model in one place so that
everybody who's using it that when they
call the API is kind of keeping get
getting the right up-to-date model but
it's not particularly user friendly
right and and the main reason why it's
not user friendly is that most of most
data scientists are not actually that
comfortable with um
interacting with apis I would say right
they don't have sort of in the back of
their mind like these are what all those
httpd status CES mean and um in order to
give any kind of validation that they're
calling this API correctly you have to
send something back and forth to the API
which can be a little bit difficult um
what we really want to do is we want to
be able to surface errors easily and
give people a lot of kind of like
handholding to help them through calling
and interacting with this API
properly let's go back to our diagram
here right so this API usually when
you're building apis you kind of want to
make them predictable and pretty strict
but not that friendly they don't it's
not that important that they're give you
great error messages or sort of guide
you along a happy path um and in order
to give that sort of uh handholding give
that sort of like ergonomics that you
want when you're building a sort of
delightful user experience it's usually
a good idea to kind of wrap that API in
a package of some kind this could be
package of any programming language
right because this API is generic um but
in this case I'm going to do just a
python one
so I have my uh python package here and
this package has just one class and this
is the way that I personally really like
um writing API wrappers which is I have
um an init method that populates the top
level URL and the headers this is really
useful um for example if I wanted to
change this URL I would have it changed
in one place um or if I wanted to devel
against a local running I could set this
URL to Local
Host and then I typically have uh
methods that are for each meth each uh
HTTP request type that I'm going to use
in this case I'm only using post and get
and um the reason why I do this is
because otherwise you kind of end up
writing basically this code over and
over again uh with all of your
particular functions so I usually have a
post get if I had other methods in my
API I would write those and the purpose
of these these methods is to first use
that that request type to call an API
with a kind of uh with the right
authentication headers and just uh
keyword arguments and then to handle
those responses so in this case I want
to surface basically that um G if it's
401 give an a python error that says you
don't have access to this endpoint and
if it's 200 um or if it's not 200 just
give them the error code and say
unexpected status code it's not your
fault it's the api's
fault and for the get endpoint it's also
going to decode it to return the actual
result um so start off so usually start
off by writing those sort of high level
methods and then write more particular
methods that give people um a little bit
more handholding so in this case I have
this upload data um argument that
uploads a panda's data frame and what
that does is first of all it gives you
checks if it has the right columns right
so rather than sending it and giving you
know some HTTP error saying like this is
the wrong data type I want to sort of
stop that before I send it to the API
before I do that post um and what I'll
do is I'll sort of give a check that
they have the right these right column
names and then if they do I will um
serialize that into a dictionary and
then post that to the endpoint this is
how I would upload sort of from code a
data set of text and annotations
um I have a simil another function query
data which takes a SQL query um and just
sends that SQL query and returns a data
frame and then I have um a two more
functions one two more methods one is uh
upload the model which uh uploads which
both gives me some type annotation that
like this is the type of model and the
type of vectorizer that I'm expecting
and will um uh and we'll sort of open
those files or we will like write those
models to disk and then post those two
files up to the model up to the
API and finally I have a method to score
the model which is very simple it just
takes the score model endpoint and sends
the text and um and a last updated one
that just will tell me the last updated
time and the reason why this is a kind
of nice uh uh user experience is that if
I am um then training the model for
example
I can have um something like this at the
top of my of my function here I have
just an API instantiate that API wrapper
class and then um when I'm getting new
training data getting the up toate
training data I'm going to use um this
the API query data method so I don't
really need to know that this is an API
I don't need to worry about making sure
I find my key in the right place
assuming I'm storing it in the
environment variable that I'm supposed
to it'll pick it up in the right way
um and I don't need to think that much
about you know like what the what the
ATP response is or turning some Json
into a data frame in the right way this
will kind of handle that all for me so
the API is handling um being the central
source of Truth for where that model is
and then the python package is building
in some sort of developer ergonomics to
make my users life a little bit
easier okay so let's give this a try um
so this is a CTO documents I'm just
going to run these
piece by piece so I've got that running
um and this is going to run it's going
to do a bunch of things and output some
model metrics gives me like Au you know
a couple of different metrics and then
I'm going to call try uploading this
data I uploaded this data and I got a
200 um so the data the two models have
been updated to the API right so for the
data scientist this is a really good
interface I'm able to get updated
training data from this API um I'm able
to train my model I'm able to deploy my
model without leaving the place that I
want to without leaving the interface
that I want to use right I want to use
code want to use maybe a jupyter
notebook or vs codes to do this type of
interaction and so here in terms of
where we're sitting we have this um this
data store we have this API these Python
and R packages and that's kind of or
this python package and that kind of
serves the data scientists if we wanted
to build an art package we would do it
in more or less the same way using um
hitter or something uh to wrap the API
so the next group of people is let's
let's tackle this leadership group and
because we've used quto uh we've
actually kind of already done that so
this is a maybe a really basic report
but it is a report that shows me you
know what is the UC and um the various
different model statistics that I might
be interested in uh for this particular
training run so how I could do that is I
could just deploy this Cordo document so
and which I've I've already done but
I'll just show you the process
[Music]
again I if I found
it oh yeah so Electronics model training
this is the uh the model training um
Dash this is the sort of model training
uh report that I'm running so this is
both training the model it's exactly the
code at same code I just showed you
before and sort of assuming this is
maybe like for a data science manager
who might be sort of familiar with this
code and want to sort of make sure that
the people who are training this model
are doing it correctly um and on the
output it's sort of generating a little
bit of just basic scores you can enrich
this by turning it into a Cordo
dashboard or adding additional plots or
things like that for this case just
keeping it very very
simple um and this actually whenever
this uh code runs on connect it is also
uploading the model right and since it's
uploading the model we can turn this
really easily into to a regular
retraining service by scheduling it so
if I go over here and click schedule
this output for default and say I want
to just retrain this model monthly so
I'm GNA sort of every month I'm going to
retrain the model you know get the
latest data maybe there's some data
that's a little bit time sensitive we
want or time time dependent we want to
have like a recently trained model um
serving this these endpoints and be able
to do that so if I um go ahead and save
this then this is going to run every
month and generate these training
statistics ICS every month and I can
also have this email to anybody in my
organization so that gives you that
ability to both sort of keep people
informed um and also um notify them when
that training has happened if we wanted
to make this a little bit more Rich for
example we could also have an error um
check for certain qualities of this
model so for example I could um check
that this accuracy was not degrading or
this a was not degrading and raise an
exception instead of doing the model
upload and then it would give you sort
of very basic um uh model monitoring for
how your training runs were
doing okay so fairly easily we've kind
of knocked out this top part of the um
of the group right we have this this
Cordo uh document that's running and
posting the model to the API our
leadership team can read that Cordo
document and we have a good code
interface for our data scientists which
both um gives them the most upto-date
model but also authenticates them to the
API in general and authorizes that that
particular user so for example if one of
these data scientists had their laptop
stolen uh we would probably the first
thing we would do is revoke their posit
connect key and if we revoked that posit
connect key then that would mean that
they wouldn't be able to access any of
this modeling infrastructure um but at
the same time we have all of the nice
error messages and good economics of a
well-designed python
package so so let's take a look at this
last group I'm going to spend a little
bit more time on the code in this one
because um I think shiny is maybe a a
newer thing maybe a little bit less
familiar uh to many people so these
annotators are going to be people who
are just in my company who are going to
manually check that the models is
producing a right the right result and
give and sort of generate new training
data for me right this is one of the
best ways especially for um things like
large language models just improving
your your model most of the time
you know you're not going to be able to
do that much better from the model
selection or tuning perspective than the
defaults this is also true with with XG
boost most of the time if you just throw
XG boost at a tabular data set it's
going to give you the best a pretty good
model for that data set um but if you
give it a better data set then that's
where you're really going to see a lot
of left so having the ability to build
an annotation capacity that is quick and
intuitive um is very
valuable um and this annotation I want
this to use a web application I wanted
to use a web application because I want
to build that user interface to make
that annotation process really fluid and
fast um so let's take a look at the uh
the end
results um and then we can uh walk
through the code so this is the
annotator which is going to take a
minute to to warm up because I think
it's starting a new
process
or it's erroring there we go okay so
just this is h i I didn't have this is
spinning up a Docker contain Docker
image or Docker container so that's why
it took a little bit of time so this is
the the basic annotation interface that
I'm building we could imagine this being
more complicated but for now what it's
doing is um it's pulling um some random
data from uh
the uh from the from the data set and
asking me basically is this El about
Electronics not Electronics or should I
do I want to just skip it and over here
I'm getting um a model score out of it
and this is letting me
um add some text to it if I do that it's
going to sort of automatically
recalculate this model score for example
I could change this to make the model
score update and it's going to allow me
to um update this data whenever I update
it's going to give me a little thing
saying marked electronics and then pull
up a new a new one so um this kind of
lets me the annotator get pretty quick
at um reading it right because I can
just look at this and say okay that's
electronics and you know I'm I'm just
like getting the new stuff really
quickly and the UI is sort of giving me
the options that I need right it's
something I'm not sure about I could
Skip and um all of these uh things are
referencing the API that we just built
right so the model score is using score
endpoint this is pulling data from the
same data source and then when I mark
them as Electronics or not Electronics
I'm appending I'm I'm adding new data to
that um that code um so let's take a
look at this in the
application so the application
is somewhere here there we go shiny
annotator um so this is the shiny the
shiny code and the thing I want to sort
of highlight is how um little is
actually happening on the server I'll
sort of go through this in a little bit
more detail um but really all I've got
here is I have this uh update prompt
function that's being called both when
they first log on and other places and
um and I have and that's kind of and
then I'm calling the uh the model score
right so what this update prompt does is
basically sends um a text or sends a
query to the to the API um to select a
random record right and then return that
string and update the uh the text
area and the reason why this is kind of
working very well is because all of the
logic is actually um included in the API
itself and in that python wrapper right
there's very little that I need to
include in the shiny app and the shiny
app can just be there for showing the UI
code and showing the um the interaction
that I want for that that uh that
code so let's walk through that code a
little bit here so um so this is the uh
app I can push this little play button
in vs code um to have it
run and um so what I have is I have um a
card with two rows and uh with a with a
row and two columns
and um this card is including um a uh
text
area uh input as well as um three
buttons for electronics not electronics
and Skip and then over here I have the
uh the model score output which is
showing me the model
score how this is uh running is when the
um when the user first first logs in I
call update prompt to update the uh uh
the text
area and then um these uh reactive
effects which is um how you respond to a
button input with a side effect is going
to um uh annotate the data with whatever
is in that text input and it's going to
use the um session user which is the
currently logged in user on connect um
to populate the annotator field and then
give me a true or false
respectively and then I'm going to show
that notification and update the prompt
right so that's going to handle um
annotating the data
and the model score uh um output is
going to be just a regular reactive so
whenever this
changes um so without other anything
other than just changing it I'm going to
call the API and hit that model
score and this works well like that's
fast enough because both the API and the
app are sitting on more or less the same
server so it's really posit connect
talking to itself so there's not a lot
of latency between the API and the and
the server so being able to have a kind
of reactive Dynamic uh model score
that's updating all the time um works
fine and then when I uh actually call
the data annotation um what I'm doing is
just wrapping that into a data frame a
one one row data frame and hitting the
uh upload data
API and we end up with this this tool
here so this is a kind of useful you can
kind of see now how this is all going to
work right so I'm going to have um some
set of data annotation people at my
company maybe this is members of the
data team maybe it's like an all hands
let's go annotate some data thing log in
for 20 minutes and go just like check a
bunch of electronics things to improve
our model
performance um I'm G to have a Cordo
document that I'm using to regularly
render that data so whenever the um
whenever the um the uh whenever this um
scheduled CTO document runs it's going
to pick up whatever the latest annotated
data is produced from these annotators
and uh posts a new model to the API and
then everyone who's using a code first
approach is going to get access to that
most up to- date best model that you
have and because it's all hosted on
posit connect it's going to be
authenticated and authorized properly
and I'm not going to need to worry about
security or regulatory problems with
it so I wanted to talk about one final
benefit of taking this approach of
splitting out um some of your
application code from a python package
or from scripts into an API which is
that it lets you move things off of
connect very easily so for example let's
say this API became very very popular
right I wanted to deploy it to
production and for a variety of reasons
I don't want to put posit connect on my
critical production path right there's a
bunch of reasons for that licenses how
much licenses cost maybe it's a single
server I don't want to over load it um
and I probably also want to not be
responsible for it as a data scientist I
want somebody else to handle all the
problems that come with with
implementing and scaling an a consumer
facing API but because I've started out
with um this internal facing API it's
very very convenient for me to hand that
off to another developer right so this
is a fast API which is a tool which can
robustly uh does robustly serve um
demanding applications and I can say to
some devops were saying look here I have
this fast API thing can you go put it on
some sort of kubernetes cluster to serve
lots and lots of people right um maybe
you don't want to have all those
endpoints but you want to have that
score model endpoint um or maybe some
other ones that you're developing and
the result is that you can develop that
API internally um by using this this
structure and then when it's time to
promote that API and send it somewhere
else you can just send that over Without
Really any type of work and you you're
sure that it's going to be correct um
you're sure that it's going to handle
the kind of the load that it's probably
that it needs to handle kind of work
through a lot of the bugs and edge
cases um and are able to sort of tell
them like okay this is what you want to
do and if we did that then um all of the
other parts of our um system would still
work right we would just need to um
update the endpoint in this python
package you know maybe redeploy the
shiny app and Cordo document to point to
the righted API um but we would be able
to um to keep working with this thing
even though we took out one part of this
project and stuck it somewhere else um
in the same way if you wanted to um
replace this Cordo uh document with a
more sophisticated pipelining tool like
you wanted to use mlflow or airflow to
do model training validation reporting
you would still be able to post from
those from those um Pipelines to this
API to update the model or update the
data store um finally if you wanted to
host your shining app somewhere else
again you'd be able to do that so having
these types of modular pieces will let
you take some swap some of them in and
out without a lot of refactoring work
and the term there um that's really
useful is called an API contract which
is basically the contractual the
relationship that you're promising
between where where these systems plug
together so like we're exposing some end
points to all these different things and
so we're kind of signing a contract that
those endpoints are going to be stable
and you know maintain their thing even
if where it's hosted or what's happening
under the hood changes dramatically
those little points of contact between
these different components of the system
will all be
there all right thank you very much for
uh for your time and I think I'm going
to be able to take some questions
now absolutely thank you so much Gordon
for the great demo and we'll jump over
to Q&A here in just a second um so it
should automatically push you over to
the Q&A room but if it doesn't I'm going
to share it in the chat here right now
but again when you go over there you can
ask questions in the YouTube chat but
you can also use this link shown here on
the screen um for anonymous questions
too but thank you again so much for
joining us today and I'll see you over
there in just a
second